[Music]
congratulations grandmaster Fabiano
carolina you just won the strongest
chess tournament in history are you
going to Disney World
no I don't think so but I'm very happy
with it have you ever won $100,000 in a
tournament before no not in one
tournament any plans for the money not
really I was talking to your coach
Vladimir to chill off and he said you
gave made him very scared when you
played h4 instead of castles are you
happy you made him nervous at least once
so far um I think it was actually a good
move I mean it seemed like the attack
played itself but it wasn't so easy and
maybe I overestimated my position a bit
well in any case I think I was never
worse I was always better and pressing
for a win and how are you gonna be able
to focus for these last two rounds
they're the same as the previous eight I
mean nothing's changed for me now where
do you put this tournament in history in
my history it's my best performance by
far and I'm not sure about the rest of
history maybe other people can decide
without that you grew up in the States
where the national championships and
scholastic chess are seven rounds were
you even able to go seven and now in any
of those championships um yeah probably
in some Junior Championship I made a
perfect score but I'm not sure if you
know you have different goals than a lot
of chess fans that wanted the streak to
continue is there any tinge of
disappointment that you're unable to
pull things out today yeah just because
I had very good winning chances at some
point but okay I mean in terms of as a
result I'm not disappointed just because
my position was still promising I feel
like there was a missed chance but well
in any case it's a good result a few
days ago I asked you if it was possible
you might wrap up the tournament with
one round to go and you've done it with
two rounds to go are you gonna allow
yourself any kind of celebration tonight
no I don't think so there's still a game
tomorrow and what about after the final
day how might you celebrate
if there's time I will are you getting
lots of you know texts and emails from
friends that you haven't heard from in a
while congratulating you know not so
many but yeah a lot of people have
congratulated me well congratulations
again it was a performance for the ages
and we enjoyed watching it thanks